chairman we're ready
thank you very much thank you for the
white ladies
and gentlemen thank you for attending
the meeting of the licensing
subcommittee today
to deal with the application for the
review of premises
license for crafty cask 33 eastwood road
raleigh the committee has listened
carefully to the representations made by
all parties
especially the concerns which are being
expressed by local residents
the committee has heard that the
evidence put forward by the
environmental health is expected is it
is
accepted by the license holder and the
representation made by the
environmental health raise serious
concerns regarding the licensing
objectives of public nuisance public
health and crime and disorder
although we note that no representations
have been made by
police or the licensing authority
additionally we have found
on the balance of probabilities that
crafty casks
have been responsible for causing a
noise nuisance to residents at old for
courts
we accept that there may have been a
failure to engage with the environmental
health officer
nonetheless we note there has been a
degree of compliance with the licensing
authority
to engage with an action plan and that
steps have been taken
all but late in the day to put in place
soundproofing however we cannot be
satisfied that such steps in themselves
will
alleviate the concerns and therefore we
believe
it we reasonable and proportionate to
impose additional conditions
on the license to promote the three
licensing objectives
referred to earlier the conditions
proposed by
environmental health will be included in
full on the license
with a variation to include bank
holidays christmas eve and new year's
eve
for door staff and the alternative
condition of tamper-proof noise limiting
device furthermore we are concerned by
the failure of management with the
premises
but not but do not believe that a change
to designated premises supervisor will
alleviate this concern
therefore conditions relating to staff
training and cctv
will also be amended accordingly the
full decision
notice will be sent out within five
working days starting from today's date
which will detail the precise wording of
these conditions
this concludes the proceedings today
thank